l'occasion de ces folles journées de
musique rue c'est grâce à irin à
chostakovitch la veuve du compositeur
nous allons maintenant vous faire
découvrir un document inédit datant de
la fin des années 40 on y voit
chostakovitch celui qui a tout accepté
et subit au nom de la musique et de la
russie y compris le pire récit michel
mompontet
il est concentré sur sa musique et rien
ne semble pouvoir le déranger aucun
bruit aucun souci
mais nous sommes en 1942 durant le siège
de leningrad
dehors les nazis pilonne sans cesse la
ville cet homme reste emile de la
tempête est l'un des plus grands
compositeurs du siècle dimitri
chostakovitch
ces images miraculeusement conservé le
montre jouant ou composants et comme on
porte une arme pour aider avec sa
musique son peuple à résister face aux
hordes nazies
stravinsky lui était à paris rachmaninov
aux états unis
autres documents historiques mais comme
un morceau d'une autre vie si éloignées
pourtant nous sommes que six ans plus
tard et le héros est devenu pour le
parti un traître il est là dans la salle
avec ses pairs mais écrasé
sa musique vient d'être condamnée pour
activités contre révolutionnaires
trop de musique pas à cette communisme
alors chostakovitch adhérera au parti il
sera obéissant et terrorisé il sera
décoré comme personne par ce parti qui
aura eu autant besoin de lui mais son
regard éternellement fuyant apeuré
rappellera que l'ordre de lénine fut
bien planter dans le coeur d'un artiste
humilié alors reste sa musique
voilà puis je vous signale cette sortie
de l'oeuvre intégrale de chostakovitch
aux éditions champ du monde y a pas
moins de seize albums éditions champ du
monde on a appris